three two one
hello everyone and welcome to the uncle
mine world autumn session
i'm luca guaya head of medical affairs
for thermo fisher scientific
and uh once again given the
unprecedented times that we're leaving
we are meeting virtually on behalf of
all term official scientific colleagues
i want to say that we're very happy to
offer you again
a very interesting uh and valuable
agenda hopefully for you as well
and so i want to thank you all very much
for joining us
so hope you had the chance to see the
message
from our president gareth hampton who
actually condensed
all the passion that we have about
oncology
testing and also shared uh some of the
plan that we have
for the near to come future if you
didn't have the opportunity to check out
that video please you can do it in the
whole
of the event also don't forget to check
out all our posters with a lot of new
data
from the oncoming solution and for now
um as we are pretty slightly late and i
strongly apologize for that
let me move forward with the first
presentation of the
part one of this event which is actually
coming from
dr nicola normando who is director of
cell biology and biotherapy unit
and translational research department at
the national cancer institute
from the ceo pascale in napoli so thank
you very much dr romano for joining us
the stage is yours and i will wait for
you right after
the presentation for the q a session
thank you again for joining
well let me first thank term official
for inviting me to get this talk
these are my disclosure and this
is the panel my talk i will start by
trying to summarize the current status
of precision coaching solid tumors
then i'll move to discussion of the
asthma recommendation for anxious
testing solid tumors
and finally i've touched upon some open
issues
and let's start first with the the what
is new now in the precision ecology
fossil tumors and of course i will start
with the
language
type in which for the first time we were
able to identify
a number of genomic alternations a
tougher potential for therapeutic
intervention
however we must recognize that until few
months ago
we had available only a few target
therapies for uh
longer than carcinoid patients and
basically drugs targeting egfr mutation
arc or lost fusions
and more recently rough mutation now
in 2020 we had available a number
of uh very interesting uh data from
clinical trials that have been published
or present in scientific media
that that are going to change really the
scenario of treatment of language
let's start with these two drugs kaplan
and devoting that showed activity in the
patient
noseboston cancer that carried the
specific meta
alteration the meth action for things
keeping which is found maybe
less than three percent on those muslim
cats response rate
a patient who had previous treatment is
41
to 46 percent and very interesting
impatient with no previous treatment
68 percent for cup material now
has been already approved by fda and i
think that we will have soon that will
solve the battery
red fusions are found maybe in one to
two percent
of those muscle and cancer now we have
two drugs that will show significant
activity
in the retribution position of muscle
and cancer blue 667
60 response rate in patient previously
treated
and cell percata 64 response rate
in again in patients had released
previous treatment
and both these drugs have been approved
by fda
up to a few years ago we did not have
available
any drug to treat the crabgrass mutant
patients
now we start to have some specific drug
that are active in
patients that carry specific
transplantation this is a
soto acid also known as
amg 510 which is active in
tumors that carry these specific keras
g12 simulation which is five pregnant
in nos muslin cancer up to thirteen
percent on northwestern cancer
carry specific mutation and these are
plenary data
showing over thirty percent response
rate in
patients that were heavily previously
pre-treated
and finally about two percent of the
nozzles and cancer patients
carry accumulation and in these patients
and over 60
responsive was obtained with this drug
that is an immuno conjugate
of an antibody directly against her tube
with the
cytotoxic drug of course i don't have
time
to go into the detail of many clinical
trials that are ongoing
but basically this is to show you how
the scenario of treatment or language
carcinoma
will specifically change in the next few
months with the number of new drugs
that have been already approved or going
to be approved for treatment or patients
that have specific genetic ratio
fortunately this advancement is not
limited uh to lung cancer
there are also other tumor types in
which we have a very interesting
results from uh target therapy
starting with the bioduct cancer in
particular interpreting conjugation
in which a number of genomic alterations
that offer potential for traumatic
intervention have been identified
as complications augmentation effigy far
fusion
adh1 and this one and the h2 mutations
we have very interesting data from drugs
targeting
uh this genetic alteration in particular
one drug penicating
an effigy far individual has been
approved for the treatment of patients
with advance of metastatic ongoing
carcinoma
who carry fgfr and fusions based on
these results
so it's showing an over 35 response rate
and finally various data are coming also
from thyroid cancer
in particular separate cutting has shown
a very good activity
in patients carrying either rat mutation
that are usually found
in patients with medullary type thyroid
cancer
or with the uh future for fusion that
are far more
in papillary and in the indifferences
carcinoma so basically what do
we expect in this next future thanks to
all these results of this clinical
trials
the fraction of all patients will
receive a
therapy that is matched to their genomic
profile within the increase
i mean in this slide the sql indicate
the current fraction of patients who are
receiving a tablet that is matched to
the
genomic profile and the arrow is uh
indicated what
is the fractional patient we do expect
will be 3d with target heavy in the next
fusion
now this advancement will be possible
thanks to
a number of biomarkers and match trucks
that are specific
for different trigger types as i shown
to you
up to now but also thanks to tumor
agnostic biomarkers and drugs
which are what are the tumor agnostic
biomarkers while
studies or genomic providing or cancer
every bit
some driver of tradition are can be
identified in different tumor types
although maybe
at a different fluid so this led to the
hypothesis
that the tumor that carry a specific
genetic alteration
might respond to the match drugs
independently
from this theological background and
actually this has been demonstrated
for the first time i think for the
entrance fusions
and transitions are found at very high
frequency in some rare tumors
that are quite rare in the most frequent
tumors
however a couple of drugs interacting in
have demonstrated that if a tumor carry
and entering fusions i mean the chance
to respond
to these androgens is identical
independently
from the histological background so
these are tumor agnostic drugs and
entrance is a tumor agnostic biomarkers
other example of tumor agnostic
biomarkers is
the macro satellite instability
a condition that is quite frequent in
some tunnels such as
endometrial cancer or correct cancer
immoral and other tumor types
what this study has shown is that the
presence
of macrocentric instability predicts
response this time not to targetary but
immunitary
to pembrolidsma and more recently i mean
fda
has also proved human national burden as
biomarker
for treating for a response to vampirism
in a
patient with solid you must receive
previous treatment based
on the findings of this clinical trial
so these data are clearly
demonstrating that the number and the
complexity of
our market that we need to test in our
clinical
practice we will need soon to test in
our clinical practice
is roughly increasing we have increased
number of genes
and maybe increasing complexity of
biomarkers
because in addition quantitation carbon
number tradition we have also gene
fusion methox from this kibby
or more complex biomarkers such as tmb
now many of these biomarkers can be
assessed by using techniques that are
able
to test a single single gene a single
biomarker
by analysis such as sequencing pcr
facial muscle chemist or it can be
assessed by using next-generation that
occurs can
access different types of biomarkers
from different genes in a single axis
now the point is that with the
increasing number complexity
of biomarkers it is unlikely that we can
continue to use methods for to test
single biomarks in our clinical practice
and this is because
the cost the time and the amount of
tissue that we need to use single
biomarker tests are not feasible in the
clinical practice
and we have a already example that this
is already happening for example
these are data of 2018 at that time the
coverage for
uh egfr and dark testing in
northwest council were pretty good
almost 100 percent in the united states
but the college for russian testing was
only 15 to 28 percent older
drugs targeting last one already
available so it's clear
that you know because muslim lack of
time a lot of tissue
this more rare biomarkers was not tested
in the majority
of patients now there are some
colleagues that still
claim that ngs is too expensive
but there are a number of statistics in
this study showing that
ngs is cheaper as compared with other
uh testing strategy at least in those
muslin currencies in which you have a
lot of
marks already improved and the ngs is
achieved also taking account the fact
that
if you use a single biomarker testing
strategy
you might need to perform additional
biopsy
in order you know to get sufficient
issue to test through the biomarkers
however we must acknowledge that in this
field there were no recommendations
and this is the reason why asmo decided
to
release a recommendation for the use of
ngs in their
practice and to do this what this group
did was first
to look at the different actual
alteration list of different axon
alterations
that are present in each transfer type
then to
perform a an escort ranking for research
generation
and then taking account only the
percentage of patients presenting level
alteration the number of level
manipulation and also the complexity of
the markers
release the recommendation for the use
of the ngs in the
daily practice but what is escape making
what are level one
the ascot is the esmoscape for clinical
actionability
or molecular targets basically this
scale indicates i mean
whether or not there is sufficient
evidence from clinical trials scientific
scientific evidence
to use a bowel marker and it's much
stronger
in the rooting clinical practice
so level one are basically the targets
that are ready
for implementation in uh looting
clinical practice for level two there
are the targets that
uh for which we have some level
awareness but we still
need additional data before we move to
clinical practice
and then of course for level three four
and five i mean the level of evidence
will be lower
as an example let's see now with the
list of genomic alterations according to
esca and in the northwestern cancer
and as shown this line basically almost
all the genetic alternations that i
discussed in the first part
so my presentation are level one eg
formulation
arc fusion methox for this gaming and
again below frost and track
red genetic alteration whereas keras
and their two are still level two
of course this is a dynamic
classification
when new data will be available from
kindle ties for chaos and that you
these uh two bar marks hopefully will
move us soon also
to level one and the same approach was
done for all the other tumor types this
year for example the kalanji carcinoma
and as i told you we have a already
number of uh
level manchester united tradition h1
jason efficiency fusions
msi and drug fusions for prostate cancer
we have
bronchosomatic mutation and the msii and
interestingly limited data for 10
delicious limitations
if we move to breast cancer we have
quite a few biomarkers but
some of these smart markers are quite
rare like a transfusion
or msi and other biomarkers such as
amplification
or pktc issue can be identified with
simple
uh tests like immunochemistry or fish
for the amplification
and you have time pcr for the few
mutations that are
targetable in breast cancer and
the same is for colon cancer which
basically
hiras and rasam birov can be addressed
basically multiplexer
pcr and then transfusions are quite rare
so
i mean if you want you can look at this
publication in nanopsychology we'll find
all the different tables all the
different tumor types
but you know but again i mean these are
the recommendations
of asthma and actually these are a
recommendation three layers there are
general recommendations for daily
practice
there are recommendations for research
centers and then there are some special
considerational patients
in the daily practice mgs is suggested
only
in lag adinocarcinoma prostate cancer
economic carcinoma
and what is suggested is you use uh
engine spawners that cover only level
one nutrition
if you want to lose larger funds you
must be sure
that i mean these do not induce
incremental costs and of course
we need to think about costs we do not
have to think only
to the cost of the panel but we have to
take into consideration so the cost
of the drug if a drug is not approved
and it's not rainbow so of course the
cost of the drug would be very hard to
treat patients outside
of the current recommendations
um ngs is also somehow suggesting colon
cancer but only
if the this not leads to additional
costs as compared to pcr
and is suggested in ovarian cancer for
black one practitioned
you know of course in the carcinoma or
noon primary and
in few tumor types for assessment of
tembi
if a tran is available if a drug isn't
improved
these are the recommendations for daily
practice however ismo recommends
for research centers really to use
larger powers because these will improve
the possibility
to detect genomic alterations that will
allow the global
our patients to chemical track and
finally and
also acknowledge that there are some
cases
which the patient and the doctor might
decide to use a large partner
what has to be clear that the advantage
from this testing outside of an academic
center is uh very limited because then
the access to drug
is highly limited so these are
the recommendations but i think that
there are few points that still need
to be uh discussed and that they're not
covered or not completely covered by the
condition
and first of all there's the problem of
the real mutation
and there's an example of viscosity and
drug fusion now
as said to the authentic fuses are quite
rare
in the most frequent tumors maybe less
than 0.5
or correct on breast nose muscle and
constipation carrying an intra fusion
and actually what is more recommends is
that
engines should not be used as screening
needed
to test for and track fusions because i
mean the cost is try
taking account to the low frequency of
the mutation so cheaper means
are really suggested how
this uh recommendation
is somehow in contrast with
a previous uh recommendation from
asmo which basically njs would suggested
only and the immune system chemist will
suggest only if ngs platforms were not
available
well what means my my personal theme
idea is that actually it's very
difficult you know to use an ngs
panel large changes panel to screen for
mgs mutation
for interacting fusion sorry uh in
particular
when uh tumors that have a very low
frequency of distributions
so it's clear that in mystic chemistry
in east asia
might be a good screen tool but still i
am convinced that
ngs should be used to confirm the
presence of the antarctic fusions
the adventure advantage of ngs is that
ngs will also provide information on
the type of fusions on the partner and
these in the long run
would be very important to stratify
better our patients
and to understand which are the patients
are more likely
to respond to a treatment another
uh tumor that was not recommended for
use of
ngs is thyroid cancer but now with the
evidence that uh
ratibs are actively bishops they carry
that mutation or refuges
i think that the angels should be used
at least for detection
of the red fusions and then we are
the there is also an important issue
when we will use this partner even if
you use a small banner
we can have some unexpected finding for
example if we are looking for
fgr far fusions in conscious carcinoma
even the smaller panel
uh uh ngs panel we will use will include
for example i cross a red fusion we can
find the last fusion
in uh colon carcinoma and you know the
only outside of
this patient in addition even the
smaller partner will include
more than a lot of drivers many drivers
and this password we find
in the tumor two different drivers this
has been for example describing those
muscle and cancer as
shown in this slide but this is like too
cold also in other tumor types
so somehow from testing we can have some
complex results and we know from
different studies that
the confidence of medical oncologists in
using and interpreting
results from genomic testing in
particular from uh
ngs balance is very low and for this
reason i think
that these results should be always
discussed within
the molecular tumor world and finally
the asthma recommendations are only
limited uh
to uh testing of tissue tissue testing
to
in solid tumors however uh we know that
there are some patients in which tissue
is not available
and we use now liquid biopsy for testing
now for lipid biopsy testing for sulfate
dna testing
we've been using up to now methods based
either on quantity pcr
or ignition pcr because they have a high
sensitivity
and and whereas ngs had
too low sensitivity to be used for
biopsy testing
but now we have a number of new methods
that uh
new and jazz meters that have improved
sensitivity
and have been developed to test software
dna and i do believe that when tissue
is not available and we need to move to
cell figuning we you should use andres
as well as we do for for for tissue for
example if
in lung cancer patients we don't have to
have tissue available
it's meaningless test only for eg
formulation
on liquid box basis of the digital pcr
we
should use an ngs also for testing
software dna
so basically these are my conclusion i
think that really position culture is
revolutionizing the classic
therapeutic approach to cancer and that
the
increasing number of uh tumor-specific
tumor gnostic biomarkers and matched
therapy will lead to
always an increase in the need to use
engineers
for human profiling in
now in the korean scenario the use of
ingest
in the clinical taxes should be limited
only uh to select the cancer types as
suggested by the esmo recommendation i
do believe that in the academic centers
we should continue to perform
comprehensive genomic funding because
only this approach will allow to
increase the use of
decision culture will increase also the
our knowledge of the mexico
that regulates sensitivity and
resistance to
target therapies this was my last site
thank you very much for your attention
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
okay
[Music]
luca can you hear me because i i really
don't hear you
don't normally i think you should are
you able to hear us
no yes yes all right perfect so thank
you very much for your presentation uh
thank you very much
was very comprehensive uh you gave us a
very nice overview about the possibility
of using ngs um
the first question from the audience is
uh
can you tell us a little bit more about
uh a
combo therapy between targeted therapy
and immunocheckpoint inhibitors how
would for example
testing play a role into this new
new scenario well let's say
first that the combination of targeted
immunity are still
experimental at least in some kind of
type
for example lung cancer we know that if
there is a strong oncogenic drug
usually the tumor does not some
stimulator although now we have some
primary findings
that specific combination patient that
have been
registered with your cpi might be active
also in presence or strong dialogue
i think that you know the true question
here is in many cases whether to go with
immune stability or
target therapy because there are for
some time it's clear
that the two uh that you approach to our
mutually exclusive
but in other cases i mean we know that
you know both attorneys could work
and this is why we need large genomic
profiling
in order to select the education that
would spawn and make an example
for example in lung cancer chaos g12c
a is predictive response to a couple of
uh
individuals that are now in the clinic
document but usually
chaos newton's encounter is also the
tumor structure that corresponds better
to neutrophils
should we see these patients first with
immune therapy
or target therapy most likely i mean if
we have a
larger genome profiling and we go more
deeply
in the knowledge of natural action of
drugs and resistance
by acquiring these evidence we could
decide
whether this patient should receive
first new therapy or target service
maybe we can also find supplementations
in which the future
approach could can be combined and we
don't have such level of events yet
yeah thank you thank you very much uh
for for your answer
and now we got a second one from the
audience
and this is about a bit more into the
direction
of the liquid biopsy i mean this is
something that we're talking about now
since uh a few years i would say
but the question is really i mean it's a
little bit general
honestly as a question but maybe it is
timely attributed now
and again the question is are we finally
ready for this now
or do you think we will keep on you know
every year we will keep on talking
about it and yet next year is coming and
the next year is coming
is this really ready for prime time in
the routine
molecular testing or are we too far away
from that
well really depends on what you mean to
be ready for the
prime time because uh uh now it is
indicated to use a liquid biopsy
for baseline molecular profiling all in
patients that have no available tissue
and in this patient i mean i think they
bring my experience out of our center
it's almost two years
that we are using liver biopsy testing
with ngs
and you know in the last four weeks we
picked up a rest fusion
and an attachment for thanksgiving i
can't say with which
uh uh which uh panel because you know
i'm not consuming
to disclose this in this session but you
know you can find a lot of violence
in addition to egf mutations when you
are not issuing it
then if we want to talk about the use of
ngs
uh liquid bypass testing to monitor
response
or for other applications that's more
complex because
of course in this case we still need
some clinical trials
and we need to prove that really if we
will focus on with which therapy
i mean we will kind of get some better
results but
i think that you know more and more we
will be using also limit biopsy
for the melting of response to patients
at least in fact in a selected
patient populations and this will help
the irs to
provide a more precise treatment to
achieve your patients but
for first one when you are not tissue
there is no question you should go with
andreas
don't waste your plasma using a
real-time pcr or double digits ccr
because you have at least five or six
targets that
are already for which you have already
available drugs and you cannot look on
it for ease
that's right so once again thank you
very much dr normano for
joining us today thanks for your
presentation and also for your
answer we will close now this q a
and move on with the next speaker dr
rotuno
uh who's actually a research fellow at
the university of florence
she will be talking about myeloid
neoplasma and clinical research around
that topic
and please go ahead to the next
speaker thank you very much
hi everyone my talk next generation
revolution in my lightning
focus on how the next generation
sequencing
in our lab cream directed by professor
vannoki at university of florence
just few slides to introduce you our
field of investigation
the classic myeloproliferative neoplasms
are clonal disorder
in its initiating by and heat
in the poetic stem cell um causing an
increased action of mature blood cells
of one of the cell lineage in the bone
marrow
or in the extra medullary sites the
three classic forms are polycytiniavera
pv essential thrombocytemia et and
primary myelofibrosis pmf
both pv and et can evolve into a
secondary form of
myelofibrosis called postpv
myelofibrosis and boss et
the three diseases are chronic but the
three can evolve
into a secondary form of acute leukemia
mpn are characterized by high complexity
and i try to summarize in this picture
on the left you can see driver mutations
of meeple
jac2 and color genes these are defined
phenotypic driver mutations since the
expression of the mutated genes in cell
lines
induces cytokine independent growth and
when expressed
in animal models it resembling
a phenotype causing myeloproliferative
disease
how you can observe pv is virtually
associated with check two mutations
um both v617f and xn12 medicines
one for essential thrombocytemia and
myofibrosis
the mutation profile is more
heterogeneous accumulation also
in color mutation and
implementation um besides
in these two apologies uh there are a
few patients about 10 percent that are
lacking
any of these driver mutations and they
are so called triple negative
and at the bottom of the figure you can
see in a proportion of these triple
negative patients
there are some non-canonic mutations
spreading genes meeple and jack 2
that has been recently described
however the mutation landscape of viola
proliferative neoplasms is made more
complex than initially believed because
of the occurrence particularly among
patients with
primary myofibrosis of additional
somatically acquired mutations targeted
genes
involved in epigenetic revelation
spliceosome
and oncogenes and these are summarized
in the table on the right
usually these mutations occur in a
metabolic cell supplements on variable
sizes
and are so called subclonal mutations
none of this mutation
is exclusive on milo proliferative
neoplasms since the
we can find it also in myeloid neoplasms
like in myeloid uh neoplasms like
chronic mellowed leukemia and
myelodysplastic syndromes
and these are the word health
organization crea for diagnosis in mpn
but this is just to show you how it's
important the molecular characterization
of this patient
especially when we are um in the lack of
a clonal market
uh marker so when we are in absence of a
driver mutation and we have to study the
wool gene
for example nipple or jack 2 or if we
have to study
a more extensive panel of genes um
it's important the biological
molecular respect and these mutations
it's important to remind that these are
the already mentioned subclonal
mutations of variable size
and in fact in this period in this room
the italian society of hematology expert
panel
are listed some recommendation about the
appropriateness of the methods for
genetic testing in mpn
and for an extended molecular
characterization
of non-canonic mutations for example
meeple or jack 2
s and in case of non-driver mutation
where an extended panel has to be
investigated ngs techniques
are recommended
so with the role of the mutations in mpn
what do they mean and how can we use it
the role in this is pathophysiology and
the clinical implication
genetic abnormalities occurring in
patients with mpm
are under active investigations in
particular
it is largely debated what is the
significance on the
these mutations instructing the
prognosis determining the clinical
phenotype
and also eventually influencing
therapeutic choices
so clinical research is very important
and it's an active field of
investigation and it's where our group
is collocated
this a translation research project
conducted from our group in 2012
in a retrospective sample covert at the
time of diagnosis of primary
myelofibrosis
it was one of the most comprehensive
study at the time
since we are talking of sanger
sequencing both in terms of samples
included and of genes investigated
we've studied the molecular asset of
almost 1000 primary
process and it translated this means
more than 60 000 single pcr
so huge cost time turning but also for
sensitivity to detect
low frequency variance however
the results of this project were very
important for the clinical researchers
in milo proliferative neoplasms simply
demonstrated that testing extended
mutation panel including at least a6 l1
idh 1 and 2 edh2 and slsf2
is an appropriate for prognostic
prediction in selected patients with
myeloproliferative neoplasms we could
identify
as gene signature that we have defined
in high molecular risk genes
show that patients are bringing at least
one mutation in any of these genes
at the time of diagnosis configure a
category at high molecular risk
and as you can observe on the left by
the graph
the high risk category showed the
negative impact
both on over survival and blast
transformation
respective patients with no mutation in
the genes that were defined
as low molecular risk on the right part
of the figure
we show that also the number of
mutations in the
in the high risk genes is a negative
prognostic factor in these patients
i showed this result just to underline
the importance of
molecular translational molecular
research
in this hematology
so the area of interest of next
generation sequencing in hematology
is as i showed you of course myeloid but
also
for the lymphoid counterpart
for our area of interest among the
myeloid neoplasms i can mention myeloid
lymphoid nucleus associated with
easyneophilia
that can show both
of egf alpha and fgm
or rearrangement of the t cell receptor
these forms of mpn are ultra rare until
now fragment analysis
by capillary electrophoresis as
represented the
most common used molecular technique to
study these variants of
t cell receptor rearrangement on the
other hand
cytogenetic with fish and molecular
biology with nested pcr
are the most used method to study fusion
genes
and of course all these methods
represent the limits of sensibility and
specificity
of the plastic molecular biology
techniques
so in clonal disease as a hematological
neoplasts are the ngs solution also for
these somatic genetic lesions could be
very useful
here it's clear how the next generation
sequencing
has grown up in this late 10 years going
from the 2008 when the first ngs
sequencer has
been placed on the market and from that
moment the interest of many
researchers in the world focused on that
and the publication spread to
uh one almost one thousand less than one
thousand in
uh 2011 um
to more than ten thousand in the last
year
of course here i picked up some example
of papers in the mythological field
but the number of papers and the
publication that i present here
is referred to the research of the word
next generation sequencing in the pubmed
database
so in all aerial signs
and now i want to show you our
experience with next generation
sequencing technique in clinical
research in our lab
we were among the first in italy to buy
the thermo fisher scientific first ngs
sequencer the iron pgm
in delay 2011 and i personally faced ngs
technique for the first time with iron
pgm
and that at the beginning it was not so
easy
of course being among the first in
general was not easy also for the
support because it was always the first
time for any kind of problem
but at the end what we can say is that
we grew up together in some way with our
field application scientist
so we had the one touch and the
enrichment instrument
and it took it to have a good manuality
with the
library preparation and the cheap
loading procedures but at the end we've
made it
as you can see on the bottom this is a
316 chip
and it it's our best cheap loading
manually loading chip so we were very
proud and we keep it as a memory
but coming back to the ngs this is one
of our first iron mpc custom panel using
used for for clinical research
it was very small including only five
oncogenes
two primary pools and
96 amplicons of course we were
quite satisfied because we used hunger
sequencing up to that moment
and instead this technique allowed us to
study up to 25 samples on a single 316
chip
so it was very quick but of course it
depended it strongly dependent
on the biologic um on the
experience of the research the
researcher
at the moment any and its manuality as
you can see in the genes included in the
panel
these are the same that we have defined
at uh
high molecular risk and this helped us
this instrument helped us to conduct
a retrospective study in different
cohort of samples
to investigate the impact of this
signature after design and pc custom
panel of course we used a lot
more compressive including gds and
regions and we have conducted we have
conducted several
research with ion pgm
but later on we decided to go through
the new ion s5
and with the new ion s5 gene studio we
have definedly improved our laboratory
practice with ngs for molecular studies
and this is one of our last custom panel
for myeloid genes it included 27 myeloid
genes
almost 300 amplicons including and
it included both tds and hotspots region
but we had a problem with the efficiency
of some primers
because the results were perfect in
silico but we
when we perform at the first rounds in
the lab
we verify that some regions were not
covered by the amplicon
or the primers were not performing well
as in silico
was described so we were forced to
design another primer pool to cover
these complex
regions and at the end we
we had four primer pools per sample
these of course resulted in higher costs
and time consuming
for project for research project that
used this gene panel the s5
was a huge step forward because it
avoided of course all the problems
related to the
initialization with the impgm with the
assessment of the ph
that was very complicated sometimes
and also the s5 case gave us more
scalability with the new
530 chip um
but a small so this was a
faster and more efficient workflow and
of course
reduced cost of sequencing a small flow
in the system if you can say so was the
manual loading of the chip for the s5
that in my experience was worse
procedure respect to the manual loading
of the chip for impgm
and at this point the technology gave us
a new possibility
and at this time at that time we
acquired we have acquired
the iron chef in our lab equipment so it
was like a technology revolution in our
lab
because at the moment was the most that
we could pretend
it was a semi-automatic procedure quick
and reproducible
it avoided the manual loading of the ips
on chip for s5 and coupled with the s5
gene studio represented the very
improvement for the lab practice
we can say all almost the same for the
study of the
fusion in our research this is uh
this is one of our first fusion gene
panels had included
51 fusion transcripts
from these genes one for example
f fib 1l1 that we used to study by nasa
pcr
has a very complicated reaction and of
more than reaction that yeah and we
application with next generation
sequencing
with the ampliseq workflow
that we were able to do at that time
very good
we finally got good results but also
very high detection rate and sensibility
for fusion genes
furthermore the tool of iron reporter
allowed us to have precise and reliable
results in a very short time
in this case the upgrade is represented
by the commercial
oncoming milloid researchers say in
particular the panel for rna
can evaluate 29
fusion genes in one single pole and five
expression genes and of course five
genes as control
we actually use it for research for
fusion genes
by library prep on ion chafter manually
and sequencing on s5
an analysis on iron reporter
and coming to nowaday i would like to
share with you our
experience with the oncoming world um
we took part of the early access of the
melloid program
in the early 2016 17. at that time we
had not the s5
yet so we participated at the program
with the iron pgm
so we did the library manually
templating on ion shaft system
and sequencing on ion pgm
we have evaluated samples that we
already studied in our cohort
so um we run six samples
of dna and six for rna on the single
318 chip and the input material
was uh very very small
because it required only 20 nanograms of
genomic dna
and 10 nanograms of 10 nanograms of rna
we had for 30 genes only two single
pools
and a simple amplisec workflow
for the analysis of the sequence from
the sequencing analysis we
we have used the ion reporter this this
was a simple
and easy workflow because the sequencing
data
were sent directly from the pygm to the
ion reporter
and we had a perfect support from the
clinica research
assistant because the consultant because
he was very present and he helped a lot
in this process
so uh later on after the completion of
the project
the new official oncoming miloid
research say came to the market
and the beginning at the beginning of
the this year
we began to use it in our research and
this time with library doing
with the library on chef and sequencing
on s5
so these of course represent the maximum
that we can have
at the moment for the lab practice um
it's a streamline process only two days
to sequence
and the library on chef is very easy and
simple
and also fast the only flaw is that you
have to work with batch
of eight samples per time so you cannot
multiplex 12 as you could do manually
and these of course in one hand it's
more expensive
for sure 30 percent more than concerning
the sequencing costs
but on the other hand i think that the
time that the researchers
is um saving doing the library on iron
chef
is more precious than money that you
could lost
run only eight sample per per round
moreover the automatic the automation
from the beginning of the
process guarantees a high quality and
standardization of all the process and
also of the results
the actual oncoming includes for 40
genes
both cds and regions requiring the same
small amount of dna or rna
depending on the application the
analysis on the ion reporter is fast
and you can configure the s5 to directly
upload sequencing data
after the run has finished
and there are frequently updated
frequently
updating of the ion reporter version and
the support is constantly present for
any problem in all the process
now i want to show you some example of
how next generation sequencing
techniques has improved our laboratory
practice in sun limits that we have
found
this is the case of a mission marian in
the jack jewel genes
gene uh it's a missense variant
and its most frequent driver mutations
in mpn samples
it's a substitution of a g to a t
that led to the v617f mutations
it is present also at very
variant frequency in the small clones
and actually the gold standard is the
real-time pcr
using next generation sequencing we
observe the very good concordance
between the two methods of course they
are not comparable since the real time
is not quantitative
but as you can see in the graph we
observe a very good correlation between
variant all frequency
obtained with the oncoming melody
researches say
and the allele burden in the real-time
pc of the real-time pcr
and as you can see it's near one so the
correlation was strong
and in this case the graph is referred
to variant with
variantly frequency less than two
percent
in fact we had the perfect correlation
in samples with buff major than five
percent
100 percent of concordance for v617f
between five and two percent and 98.5 a
concordance between
two percent and 0.5 variantly fraction
this is just to tell you that the real
time is still the gold standard for the
detection of these variations
in the for diagnostic purposes but in
our opinion
for research purposes ngs could
represent a good alternative to real
time giving
also the possibility to researchers to
screen
large number of targets
this is the case of a large indel in the
gene karate equilibrium
um this the indels of the axon line of
cortical and genes
gene have been described uh in the late
2013
and consists for the most part of in
large indels
the most frequent is a deletion of 52
best pair
and with our first panel uh custom panel
including curriculum jean
we were not able to call the variant as
you can see in the picture on the
on the left
this is a sample that we already have
confirmed with other technique
um sanger sequencing and capillary
electrophoresis
are the classic molecular techniques
used to study this kind of variants
but in our experience after the failure
of the first custom panel
we decided that we needed we needed to
design a super amplicon
covering the region interested by the
deletion
and in the meantime we decided to switch
at the
to use the 400 best pair and pc
chemistry
because the length of the deletion was
more than one third of the amplicon
and this is the kind of length
proportion limit for bioinformatics
tools to call a dna intel
with these changes we managed to get
good call quality with a custom panel
actually the oncoming melloid research
assay
can call the indel of karetiglin and we
tested the panel with samples
that have very low variant allele
frequency in dell
also in this case next generation
sequencing can help
researchers to detect dna variants with
more sensibility and specificity respect
to standard molecular tests
this is my last example this time as an
insertion of a guanine in a stretch of 8
g this variant is one of the most
frequents
in the a601 gene and it's present
instead
its presence instead of an artifact have
been discussed
for many years in literature and also in
our group we decided to study this
variant
in a retrospective study in a cohort of
clinical sample with myelofibrosis
and we confirmed the presence of the
variant and also its negative impact on
outcome in this sample as you can
observe by in the kaplan-meier curves on
the right
the samples displaying the institute in
red
had worse overall and leukemia free
survival
respect to those with other types or no
variants in a6l1
but in this case next generation
sequencing
was not useful and in the figure you can
see the whole
and the lack of reads in the region
interested by the insertion
in the middle there is the stretch of g
and we had very poor sequencing data so
we decide also in this case to design a
super amplicon
covering the region to get better
results
but we tried both the short amplicon
design and also the 400 ones
but also with the uncommandment lloyd
researchers say we concluded that
it's impossible to make the insertion
call in this region
so concluding for this specific
insertion in the a601 gene
we'll still have the problem and we used
to perform sandwich sequencing
even if we are aware just to lose small
clones
in conclusion i can say that
hematological samples
are very heterogeneous and given their
molecular complexity
next generation technologies may become
fundamental for the in-depth
characterization
and study of this kind of samples
next generation methods are shown to be
useful to for
translational and clinical research
giving the possibility to study lots of
targets on many samples
at the same time with a very good
sensibility
this helps to have rapid and complete
molecular information
about the samples in the study and
regarding the more technical aspects
i can say that the oncoming mellite
research essay
coupled with iron chef doing the library
on chef and templating on chef
is a streamlined workflow it's the
fastest solution that we have in the lab
at the moment
of course in this period the new
possibility has faced on the market with
the gen xs
and probably we will think about it in
the future
the possibility to have the iron
reporter software tool dedicated to this
specific panel
it's very useful iron reporter is
continuously updated with the aim to
give back
analysis of the data even more clean and
specific
and finally the support by the clinical
application
research consultant is fundamental and
it's always present
and thank you for your attention
and thank you very much again
for your presentation very very uh
interesting
comprehensive and also i appreciate very
much you sharing your
very personal experience uh using first
the pgm and then moving on
with a higher level of automatization
uh with uh with the iron chef and the s5
so again
thank you very much for that very
practical uh
you know experience so now we will move
on now to the
question for your presentation and the
first one
is uh is about in general the rule of
the
of the angiosperological uh disease now
you have shown
some very peculiar application meaning
that
that you have shown how you're using ngs
for some very specific
disease but the question here is about
do you see in the near to come future uh
the application of ngs also expanding
outside the the the hematological
disease that you have just uh
shown so in other words do you see a
much higher uptake
in the general hemong field of ngs
although you still see it
very well defined only to some very
specific
diseases okay thank you for the question
i think that with the new technique
for study by molecular biology we will
have
even more a great number of genes
for many hematological diseases
we started like as you said with a small
panel in our experience and then in few
years we moved to
a very extended panel i think that this
possibility can of course be extended
also to other
uh kind of
disease
instead of only mild proliferative
myeloid of course because
these new molecular techniques like ngsr
let you study a lot of target per time
and then
when you go for phishing research as we
used to call
like when you for example discover a new
gene implicated it's
more easy with ngs to
study a lot of
genes in the same run so
in the same experiment so i think yes
for sure ngs can be
useful al also for other uh diseases yes
all right thank you thank you very much
for that now
another question for you it's actually
let's say
continuing of your story you have moved
from pgm which was honestly a very
complicated instrument for a number of
reasons
it required a lot of manual working and
then you moved on to the iron chef s5
and that's yet
another opportunity now with the new
iron toronto genesis system
how do you see in your experience
the importance of having high level of
automatization
so what is the real benefit that you
have seen
again passing from the pgm to the to the
s5 have you seen less error have you
gained you know
uh have you been able to reduce the
turnaround time what was your main
advantage
for you yes of course the turnaround
times is of course
reduced drastically reduced the
hands-on time of the researcher is of
course reduced because of course you
can do more research respect to manual
uh
preparation and operation in the lab so
you can
evaluate more aspect and and you have
more time to doing real
research of course there is a
standardization
higher than the manual the then with the
manual preparation of the library and
the data are clean and more
reliable yes i think this this is very
the automatization is very useful we
don't have genexos as i told you
but uh of course it's a possibility that
we are evaluating for the future because
of course
uh molecular biology and ngs techniques
are
taking uh even more space in our
research
so of course automatization is uh
the first proceed the the preferred
profi
procedures in our lab yes all right
thank you very much again also for this
question and now another one which is
coming in the direction of
mrd minimal residual disease monitoring
uh you know that's a very hot topic at
the moment it's only used uh
in in certain hemang especially you know
in the context of
ill so the question is again how do you
see now minimal residual disease
expanding also outside let's say the
classical
uh nowadays uh implication and also
do you foresee there's gonna be an
increase in terms of a burden
from from the laboratory that are
involved in mrd because there's gonna be
many more cases
in which people will want to use mrd
as a tool to assess you know patient uh
let's say progression yes of course yes
this this is a very hot topic at the
moment
also because do you know
there are some tricky points with the
ngs analysis
for example how uh in-depth you can do
with the vaf
for example but i think that in our in
our
experience uh we can evaluate a sort of
mrd with ngs also for hematological
disease for example
we have conducted a study
retrospective study on samples after the
transplantation the bone marrow
transplantation
and we observed that
a real good i can see
um a real good correlation with the
variant
present at the moment before the
transplant
and then after the transplant and when
the
the disease started again and for um
and so we can evaluate also
with ngs uh the the clones
moving in the you know in the disease
so i think that it's a it's a hot topic
but of course uh
you have to be very sure and very
practiced with interpretation of data
and also
with the standardization of your
technique because of course
there is the problem of the force
positive the technique problems
and so i think it's important to have a
very good standardization workflow in
the lab
before doing this because there are a
lot of
helps from the you know from the company
from the kit
but you have to take uh very
very careful the data that you have you
have to be really sure to do
mrd with ngs i think but it's possible
all right thank you again also for this
answer so now
jada i'm gonna close the q a i would
like to thank you once again for joining
us as a speaker in this event
uh really excellent presentation and
also thanks for taking the time to
to answer to those questions so now to
everyone um we're gonna have a break of
about 10 minutes because we were
slightly
late today uh please take the
opportunity
to go get a coffee and also have the
chance to navigate
the event by looking at the presentation
hall and the poster hall
and we will be back here for the next
presentation
in about 10 minutes once again thank you
all very much for joining us today
thank you luca bye ciao